in South Carolina the defense has rested
in the double murder trial of disgraced
lawyer Alex Murdock the final defense
witness Murdoch's younger brother
prosecutors expect to call a few more
witnesses today naked Batiste is at the
courthouse in Walterboro South Carolina
Nikki good morning
good morning John Marvin murdaugh told
the jury he found his brother destroyed
and broken after the murders but perhaps
one of the more emotional parts of his
testimony came when he described
returning to the crime scene after it
was released back to the family
I saw blood I saw brains I saw pieces of
skull or and when I say brains it could
just be tissue yeah I don't know what I
was saying it was just it was terrible
Alec murdal's younger brother broke down
Monday as he described cleaning up the
remains of his nephew Paul the day after
he was murdered felt like it was the
right thing to do
I felt like I owed him
and I started cleaning
and I promise you no mother or father or
Aunt or uncle
should ever have to see and do what I
did that day Murdoch has repeatedly
denied murdering his 22 year old son and
wife Maggie and in an attempt to prove
his innocence the defense called an
expert witness who suggested two
Shooters killed Maggie and Paul murdaugh
why would one shooter bring two long
rifles two long weapons to the event you
can't handle and shoot two of them but
during cross-examination the prosecution
pointed out that he only visited the
crime scene last Friday you know if you
review the entire case File
you just reviewed materials that were
provided to you after listening to
testimony for more than five weeks the
jury will soon get a chance to leave the
courtroom the judge granted a request by
the defense to allow them to visit the
sprawling Murdoch hunting estate where
the murders occurred
the jury will visit that property after
testimony from four or five rebuttal
Witnesses for the prosecution expected
today if things stay on schedule closing
arguments could be tomorrow Tony
all right we'll keep following it Nikki
thank you very much